لإبقاء الاتحاد السوفيتي بعيدًا عن
الأمريكيين والألمان ،
هكذا وصف أول أمين عام للناتو على الإطلاق
مهمة المنظمة في
الأصل منظمة معاهدة شمال الأطلسي
التي تهدف إلى حماية الأعضاء
من التهديد الذي يشكله الاتحاد السوفيتي
ولكن مع هذا التهديد ذهب عندما ذهب الاتحاد
السوفيتي.  كافح الناتو المنهار من أجل
إعادة تعريف دوره وأهميته
حتى الآن
لا يوجد شك في أن
الناتو ذو صلة
فهو فعال ومطلوب الآن
أكثر من أي وقت مضى.
إن مصالحك
التي تأسست في الأصل من قبل 12 دولة في
عام 1949 يقف الناتو قويًا مع 30 عضوًا
اليوم ، وهو مبدأ رئيسي للدفاع الجماعي
واحد للجميع والجميع
للواحد المنصوص عليه في المادة 5 من
المعاهدة التأسيسية التي تنص على أن هجومًا مسلحًا
على عضو واحد يعتبر
هجومًا  على جميع حلفاء الناتو
في الواقع ، هذا يعني أن أي عضو يمكنه
الاعتماد على ما يقرب من 3.5 مليون
جندي ومدني كوم
لا نسعى إلى أي نزاع ، لكن إذا
جاء الصراع إلينا ،
فنحن مستعدون له وسندافع عن
كل شبر من أراضي الناتو
التي تعتبر حاسمة بالنسبة للبلدان الأصغر
التي ستكون بلا حماية بدون
حلفائها ، لذا فإن الناتو هو حقًا أفضل
ضمان أمني يمكنك الحصول عليه
في الوقت الحالي ، في عالم اليوم ،
فإن الدول الثلاثين التي تجعل
الناتو هي التي تقرر حقًا
أولويات العمليات والميزانية ،
لا تأتي هذه القرارات
بسهولة دائمًا مع تمويل الناتو الذي يثبت أنه
نقطة شائكة في الماضي ،
وعلينا أيضًا التأكد من أن أعضاء الناتو
يلتقون بهم  الالتزامات
المالية ودفع
ما يدينون به للكثيرين الذين لم يفعلوا
ذلك
بموجب إرشادات الناتو ، يجب أن
ينفق الأعضاء 2٪ من ناتجهم المحلي الإجمالي على
الدفاع كل عام ، ولكن في السنوات الأخيرة ، قام
عدد قليل من الأعضاء بذلك ،
ويعتمد الناتو أيضًا على مساهمات
القوات من أعضائه.  ليس
لديها جيش خاص بها ،
كانت هناك علامة استفهام كبيرة حول
مستقبل الناتو في نهاية الحرب الباردة
، وهي الظروف والأزمات بطريقة ما
أعطى الناتو في كل مرة هدفًا جديدًا
بدأ مع الأزمة في غرب
البلقان ثم تحول سريعًا
إلى تحالف للمساعدة في مكافحة
الإرهاب بعد 11 سبتمبر وخاصة
مع أكبر عملية له على الإطلاق في
أفغانستان
تطورت الناتو وتوسعت بمهام جديدة
تتراوح بين  من الأعضاء الذين يعملون
كقوات حفظ سلام في البوسنة إلى مكافحة
الاتجار بالبشر إلى اعتراض اللاجئين في
البحر الأبيض
المتوسط ​​والآن من الواضح أن فلاديمير بوتين
يشن ما يسمى بحرب العدوان
ضد أوكرانيا ، الأمر الواضح هو أنك
بحاجة إلى منظمة مثل الناتو
[موسيقى]
بدأ فلاديمير بوتين عمله  الحرب في
أوكرانيا التي طالبت بأن يقوم الناتو
بإعادة حدوده إلى ما كانت عليه في
التسعينيات والتي تم رفضها بسرعة
ولا شيء يوحد مجموعة أكثر من
عدو مشترك كما أشار الأمين العام لحلف الناتو
قبل الغزو إذا كان
هدف الكرملين
هو تقليل حلف الناتو  على
الحدود ، لن تحصل على المزيد من الناتو إلا بعد
ثلاثة أشهر بعد 200 عام من
عدم الانحياز العسكري
للسويد هكتار  اختاروا مسارًا جديدًا
، وقدمت السويد وفنلندا طلباتنا الرسمية
للانضمام إلى الناتو ، وهو تحرك رمزي
من البلد حتى خلال أكثر
لحظات الحرب الباردة توتراً لم
يشعر بالحاجة إلى الانضمام إلى التحالف ،
إنه في الواقع دفعة كبيرة
للأسرة الأوروبية لأنه  لديك
عضوان في الاتحاد الأوروبي
ينضمان إلى الناتو وهذا يجعلني أعتقد أنه
يخلق تداخلًا أكبر بين هذين
الناديين ، حيث سيضيف البلدان قوة نارية
ودفعًا جيوسياسيًا لحلف شمال الأطلسي.
تريد
أن يكون لها موقف دفاعي ورادع موثوق به
ضد
صعود روسيا الفنلندية بشكل خاص
سيعني أن أمة تشترك معها روسيا
في حدود 830 ميلًا ستصبح
متحالفة عسكريا مع الولايات المتحدة
في الوقت الحالي ، يبدو أن خطط بوتين أدت إلى
نتائج عكسية في حربه وحدت الغرب
ضد موسكو.  بطرق كانت تبدو
غير متوقعة من قبل
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]